- What happens in the end of Robin Hood,
how does it actually end?
Do you know, you're laughing?
Caleb, do you know?
Seth?
Zach?
Get over here, come and
tell, me we found somebody.
Who the fuck is the Sheriff of Nottingham?
Yeah!
You got your perspective.
(crowd cheers)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat music)
- Having absorbed your
content, watched you,
I consider you the modern-day Robin Hood.
And before I explain what what that means
tell me your initial thoughts on this.
- You're smarter than you look.
(laughs)
Honestly, I don't, I'm
trying to think right now
'cause I don't want to bullshit,
I think you might be the first person
to say that recently, ever maybe even,
and I think it's very interesting
'cause it's crossed my
mind multiple times.
- Here's what I'm getting,
a long time ago there are these ideas
and these these thoughts
and these collaborations
were for the super successful, super rich,
the Rockefellers, all these people.
And what you've done is you've
said, all right, no more,
you can look at Sasha
that you just started,
you can look at the way you do things
and you're making it
available to everybody.
And if that's not Robin
Hood I don't know what is.
- And to your point, Sasha's
a company I'm building
but like my great legacy
in my aspiration to be
someone that gets written
about like Robin Hood
is giving it for free.
- Yeah, that's it.
- If somebody asked me
what are you most proud of
I'm literally giving away
all my best shit for free,
I don't know what else to say.
And to your point, you're right,
I go into the clouds with
all these interesting places
and people and things
and I come back every day
and I produce content
for the masses for free.
- What's amazing about that
is you've built a business on,
or you've built a profitable
company, a business on it,
but you're rising up the people who
believe they never had a chance.
- Well think about people
that kind of look like me
if you do know who I
am, a lot of people that
kind of look like me build
audience to the masses
but then try to sell to that audience.
Right, here's the $4,000 ebook,
here's the come to my master mind.
What I do is, back to your analogy,
that's why I thought of it too,
I do business with Chase and Budweiser
and triple A list celebrities.
But for the masses it's free.
- It's crazy, and the
masses and the celebrities,
they sign up for that shit.
They sign up, they're onboard
because that's your brand,
they understand that.
- They also understand
word-of-mouth, reputation matters.
Like, I really know
what I'm talking about.
And when I meet anybody,
and by the way, this right,
we've had to move this
podcast a couple times,
I've got this weird day,
now I come and sit down say,
hey I got 20 minutes not 30 right,
but like for these next 18 minutes,
like I'm giving everything I've got.
Like, I'm not thinking about,
I don't even know what my next meeting is.
I don't, there's a million
fires I have going on,
I don't give a fuck, I
need to deliver to this,
and I think that's what I
do well for any audience,
whether it's celebrity,
the masses, client,
like I'm obsessed with over-delivering.
It's why I say yes to shit
like this in the first place,
the fact that you're gonna be
able to build a bigger podcast
by leveraging the fact that I was a guest
is the single reason I'm
doing this interview.
The singular reason I'm doing
this is I know where I sit
and what it will mean
for you by leveraging me.
That's meta as fuck.
- 100%, but that's Robin Hood shit.
- I couldn't agree more.
Listen, I literally, that was my reaction,
you're smarter than you look.
It's a very, very smart observation.
And I'll tell you this, it
actually, it's really funny,
I judge people on how they figure me out.
It's funny where my brain
went when you said it,
A, interesting I'm pumped
that you figured it out.
B, oh shit, he figures shit
out that isn't obvious.
- Listen, I super appreciate that,
I'm gonna roll and keep goin',
- Go go go.
You don't want compliments the whole time?
- No, no, thanks, I'll
take that shit later.
So, 2009 you were asked a question,
where in New York do you love
going when you're in town.
And you said, I love going to my barber's,
I love gettin' my hair cut,
we have, me and my barber,
have great conversations.
What was the last great
conversation you had,
and I'm not talkin' about the conversation
in front of the camera, I'm talkin'
the last conversation you left--
- I cannot believe this is the question.
Had you asked me 48 hours ago
I wouldn't have known the answer,
I would've like thought really fast.
Yesterday, Travis Kalanick,
the founder of Uber,
and former CEO who's,
you know, been out there,
stopped by, we're long time friends,
I often talk about passing on Uber
and losing out on all those dollars,
we had a great conversation.
Like, thoughtful as fuck.
- No camera, just you
and him, or were cameras?
- No cameras.
- So in that moment,
right, I don't need to know
what the conversation was, but--
- I'll tell you right now.
In that moment I was reminded
why he was able to build
one of the fastest growing
businesses of all time.
And it wasn't a business
conversation, he's just thoughtful.
Listen, I'm gonna pass
you another compliment,
I like when people see shit
that other people don't.
It's actually how life works.
Let me give you something
I'm hot on right now,
I do not think the American dream
should be buying a home anymore,
I think it's full of shit.
- Tell me more of that shit
- It's fuckin' bullshit.
It's a bad use of up front capital
and it ties you up and
it's just not smart.
- It's not gonna appreciate.
- And what is it for?
Like, I'm pissed that I own a home.
I would literally rent in
perpetuity now, and I will.
Like, I will never buy another new home.
College, parents are tricked
forcing kids to go to college
when 93% of kids should not go to college.
I love when shit is accepted
but it's now broken.
Because college and buying a home
might've really been awesome,
and I actually believed
this in 1954 and 1973,
the problem is it's 2019.
So like I'm hot on seeing things
that are obvious to me on
what's gonna happen next.
Heres what we do very
interestingly as a society,
we shit on the new and we
put the past on a pedestal.
- Mhm, no question.
People buy homes, people buy fancy cars,
and they go to college for
one reason, for significance.
- 100%, acceptance.
- Acceptance, right.
- But here's the thing, real quick,
let me tell you the
difference between a Lambo
and owning your own home.
I'm looking at some people here,
we're all looking at each other, right?
You just don't know if
you own a home or not.
Like, you don't have to know.
Like I know you're driving
a fuckin' Lambo, I see it.
But you live in a home, I
actually have no fucking clue
how much mortgage you have on that home,
do you rent it, right?
I'm telling, you this
thing, and by the way,
this is my thesis to why it will fall.
I'm not saying fashion will
fall, fashion will never fall,
I gotta show you that
I'm wearing fly fuckin'
Clouds and Dirt, or a
Gucci bag, or Under Armour,
like that's how we express, but on a home,
I actually don't know I you
if you own it or you rent it
and that's why it's vulnerable
'cause it actually doesn't
matter to the outside person.
It's not important, it matters
that you're in that home.
And if you actually play it out,
it means people are gonna
live in much better homes.
'Cause if you're not using
all that up front cash
and you're just renting
you can go higher up,
hey, you can be in a fancier place.
It's very, why do you need to own a home?
To leave it to your
kids, they can rent too.
Oh, this is some fucked
up amazing shit for me.
I think the whole thing is gonna go,
in the next 50 years, it
takes time to rebrand.
- In a while.
- Yeah, go.
- All right, next question,
so I know you have this--
- By the way, everybody who's listening,
that's is how you go from,
what was the last meaningful
conversation you had
into ranting about the current state
of home ownership in America,
if you were just curios.
Go ahead.
- Good transition there, we're
like speed rounding here.
So, I know that you and
your, from what I've heard,
you and your wife have an agreement
that you kind of don't talk about family,
you've set some boundaries.
- In my content, yes, correct.
- Question though, what
principles did your mom teach you,
I know that she taught
you how to be confident,
that you, if you had to come up with
the three principles that you're
gonna pass on to your kids
that your parents taught you,
what are those three principles?
- Beautiful, so I would say, hot take,
it's less about principles.
Number one, rule number one,
disproportionately over love your child.
In parallel, in parallel to you
building up that self-esteem
you eliminate all delusion.
What my mom did that I
don't see most people do
is she wildly made me
think I was the best,
but anytime it was proven that I wasn't,
she acknowledged that I wasn't.
Confidence not at the expense of reality.
So you have two groups
of parents, the masses,
one insecure parents who
pass their insecurity
onto their kids and
they shit on their kids,
thus making kids think they suck.
Or parents that over coddle
and bullshit their kids
and give them 8th place trophies
and make them think like,
my son yesterday said he's gonna dunk,
and I said, you are never gonna dunk,
right to his fuckin' six year old face.
I'm like dude, you will never dunk.
He said, why, I said, DNA.
He's like, what's DNA, I'm like ask Alexa.
- [Chad] (laughs) Google that shit.
- It was important for me to not be like,
yo you're gonna dunk, he's not gonna dunk,
and as soon as he
understands that the better.
That's not what most parents
do, so my mom over loved me
and gave me unbelievable self-esteem,
but she taught me accountability
and eliminated entitlement.
Do you understand?
I'll tell you, everything else
she did doesn't mean shit.
It's tier seven importance,
be kind, loving,
all that, amazing stuff, hard work, cool,
I promise you, it's two things.
Build self-esteem, make your kids
think that they could do anything
until they prove they can't
and then acknowledge they cannot.
I'm big on this, and that's
what I do with my employees.
Like, go go go, and then you can't,
and you're no longer on the video team,
or you can't write anymore.
And that's the way it should, I love that.
- What does that do for them in the long,
give me the cause and effect of that shit.
- The effect is, you try shit
and you don't fear failure,.
the end.
Do you understand what
happens when you stop worrying
about other people's opinions and failure?
Like, everything opens up.
And when you take on full responsibility.
See, optimism and confidence
at the balance of reality versus delusion
makes you fear failure, not
value other people's opinions,
and have complete and
utter accountability.
That shit gets real good.
This is why I push, it's your fault.
I generally think everything
in my life is my fault.
- [Chad] And it's liberating as hell.
- You know how fun it is to
know that nobody has control?
When you say it's Rick's
fault, Rick has control.
- Yeah, I love that.
One of the questions I
ask my kids every day,
tell me how you failed today.
And the first time I
asked them, defensive,
like what are you talkin
about, I didn't fail.
- Nothin' fuck you, dad.
- Right, and now it's
like, oh I tried this
and it didn't work out
and now like that's their badge of honor.
- And look, I'm pissed when I fail.
Like, you don't wanna raise
people that like just,
yeah, I lose at everything,
there's accountability slash,
you know what my mom
taught me, ramifications.
I'll give you a good one.
My mom knew I was gonna
be a fuckin' winner,
let's just call it what it is.
But she punished me on the
clock four times a year.
Every fuckin' report card I would go down,
no TV, no friends, no
Nintendo, it was the worst,
it was fuckin' clockwork
for a decade, she did it.
'Cause even though she knew
it wasn't gonna matter in the macro
in the micro it's what I was doing
and if you fail you have accountability.
- Listen, I graduated with
a 2.0 grade point average,
never went to college,
and I'm coaching CEOs
of billion dollar companies right now.
- I mean, you've done your
homework, you have contacts,
like, I love sharing my report card.
- But let me ask you a
question to that point,
there's was a time when that
was my greatest weakness,
I hid that shit.
- Yeah, me too.
- Like, wouldn't talk
about it or sugar coat it,
but now what I've learned
is I've flipped that shit
and I open up with that shit.
- 8 Mile, 8 Mile.
- Once DRock, once Papa Dock knows all,
what are you gonna say about me, right?
- What are you gonna say?
- What are you gonna say about me?
- Naked, if this could all play out
that we just all roll naked and like it's,
and when I say naked, look,
maybe we do physically roll naked,
but like, let me promise you
something, hypocrisy smells.
Whenever somebody judges
somebody else I always laugh
because I know that they have
something they suck at too
or they're hiding too.
- I love that, one of the
best books I ever read,
Mistakes Were Made, but Not by Me.
And it was all about
hypocrisy and the judgements.
- I hate that shit.
- And that's what we live in,
we live in this world now.
- Every day I wake up, at some level,
subconsciously or
consciously I always say,
who the fuck am I?
You know what I mean?
With all the good shit, I think I'm dirt.
I mean it, nobody's gonna
give a fuck a year after I die
except for like 11 people, it's the truth.
- The 11 people that are in that room.
- Nobody's gonna give a,
for all the things like,
all the people that don't know what to do
when they see me at the
airport, I take a selfie, right?
Like, what, what?
The Macho Man Randy Savage,
I'm looking at his fuckin',
I love him so much,
what happened, he died,
I was fucked up for like four hours,
and then the next day happened.
- And then you went on with your day.
- Yeah.
- You know how says that shit,
you know who says that shit?
- Who?
- Robin Hood says that shit.
- No.
- Robin hood says that shit.
- Is this true?
I never read Robin Hood.
- No, well Robin Hood says the shit that
I'm just doing what I
do and you know what,
I'm not doing it for any other reason
but it's the right thing to do.
- How does Robin Hood end?
- What are you talkin' about?
- I'm being dead serious,
I don't know what the fuck,
Robin Hood the book, right?
- Yeah, Robin Hood the book
and then they had a movie,
Kevin Costner.
- I didn't watch that shit.
What happens in the end of Robin Hood,
how does it actually end?
I'm being dead serious, I have no,
do you know, you're laughing.
You don't know, right?
Hold on, real quick, do you know?
Do you know?
Look, there's five people
in here, one of you, you,
is like, you don't know?
News alert, the four of us have,
open the door real quick.
(laughs)
yo, Caleb, do you know
how Robin Hood ends,
the book, the movie, like do
you know how Robin Hood ends?
- [Caleb] No.
- Of course not, Seth, do
you know how Robin Hood ends,
like the book, Robin, no idea.
Zach, get over here, come and
tell me, we found somebody.
Justin, Justin, do you
know how Robin Hood ends?
- [Justin] Which Robin Hood?
- The fuckin' book, I don't know.
- Or the movie, pick one.
- [Justin] How Robin Hood ends?
- Yeah, how does Robin Hood
end, the story of Robin Hood.
- [Justin] He kills the
Sheriff of Nottingham
and gives the money to the people.
- He gives the money
back to all the people.
- Who the fuck is the
Sheriff of Nottingham?
- He's the tyrant!
- [Justin] And they just
released another Robin Hood.
- I gotta go soon, well let me get,
speed round, two questions, I'm out.
All right, good, thank you
for knowing Robin Hood,
see ya Zach, Justin.
- You just took 30 seconds
trying to figure out
who the fuck Robin Hood was.
- This is the best podcast
of all time, by the way.
- So now we went from family,
so let me ask you a question,
so now that you have this,
you come from Russia,
I'm gonna go all the way
back, you come in from Russia.
- Belarus, for everyone scoring at home,
I come from Belarus.
- You go outside to play football.
- Oh, right, I go from,
for everybody at home,
Belarus to Queens, Queens to Dover,
Dover to Edison, New Jersey, I'm five,
I go outside in August 1982--
- And Eric says.
- And Eric Godfrey.
- Says you are a--
- Jets fan.
They're throwing a Nerf football around,
I'm just getting acclimated
to America, right,
'cause I'm an immigrant, this
football thing seems fun,
we're throwing around,
remember the old Nerf,
and they're like, who do you like?
I'm like, I have no idea,
and Eric Godfrey goes,
you're a Jets fan, and that's
how I became a Jets fan.
- So let me ask you a question.
- Please.
- 40 years later, 40 years
later almost to the day,
your entire empire, your entire life,
has been predicated on
this one statement, right.
This, I set the goal, the bell goes off
and I start fuckin' running.
- That's right, I'm gonna buy the Jets.
- I'm gonna buy the Jets,
What happens when you buy the Jets?
- Two very opposite reactions.
One, I don't give a
shit if I buy the Jets,
I just wanna try to buy the Jets.
It's a very big thing,
this process, this chase,
the thrill of the hunt
is everything to me.
My intuition is one of two things happens,
there is some weird, awkward lull of like,
micro moment of depression of
like, okay, I did it, right,
and it'll be crazy because
I'm a marathon runner
so it's not happening for 20 years
and so like over the next 20 years
think about how many people in America
are gonna know about this
goal, almost everybody.
- [Chad] Five million know
about it now, minimum.
- That's right, and so a
lot of people are gonna know
and then I hope it quickly goes into
and now I have to
fuckin' win a Super Bowl.
So my hope, and this is my intuition, is
it will quickly transform
into the task at hand.
- So how many Jet stadiums
do you think you fill.
with the people's lives
that you've changed
in your quest to buy the stadium?
- So, 70,000 is a stadium.
I would say, by the time
it happens or today?
- People's lives that you have changed
just because of your quest.
All this shit doesn't happen
if it's not for the quest,
and so how many lives do
you think you've changed
by the time you reach it.
- Let me say something
I want everybody to know
and I'll put it on wax,
as they say, right now.
The fact that I get one
of the emails I get a day,
and I get a lot of them,
that says I was suicidal,
like real shit, shit that's heavy,
that trumps anything I will
every do professionally.
One, one person telling you
that they were going to take their life
and that you're fuckin' videos
and podcast made them not
is disproportionately greater
than if I bought all 32
NFL teams, and I mean that.
So you can imagine why
I'm such a happy kid.
That being said, man, a lot man.
Look, I'll be very honest with you,
I'll put it again on wax, people
come up to me all the time
and go, Gary, you've no idea
how many people's lives your impacting
and I always hate that.
Because in my mind I'm
like, you have no idea
how many people's lives I'm impacting
that I realize I'm impacting
and more importantly,
how many I'm gonna impact.
Oh, and by the way,
this is what makes me so
happy about the way I was parented,
this has nothing to do with me,
this has to do with the
circumstances of America,
when I was born, and most
importantly, my two parents DNA
and what they did with
the clay that I was.
So when I say that I genuinely think
that I can be a generational person,
and that's what I think, I'm
gonna be very weird right now,
I think I can be a generational person,
that all four of you with talk in 45 years
that you spent time with
me 'cause I'll be such,
I actually believe that.
I believe it, I think it's
going to be many, many, many,
I plan on genuinely impacting
millions and millions
and millions and millions and millions,
if not hundreds of millions of people
because I know what my,
really my only vulnerability is my health.
I know what my intent, my
intent is only to have a statue.
Quote unquote, right,
like I want to be admired.
My sister got emotional the other day
just seeing how many people I'm impacting,
and I said, sis, November 14th's
gonna be a national holiday.
Obviously it was Martin Luther King day
so it was on my mind, I was like, fuck it,
why not, why not?
- Why not?
- Like, I understand the
words coming out of my mouth.
- If more people felt
that way on the same shit.
- By the way, you don't
get national holidays
for buying the Jets.
You get national holidays
for moving the culture.
And when I say the culture
I'm talkin' humans.
And so I'm very excited about my ambitions
and I understand they're audacious
and I understand why some people listening
are like, ew, this guy,
I understand how it can
sound like big head,
I promise you if you peel away the onion,
I wish more people were doing it.
- I'm with you, last question
'cause I know you gotta go,
last question, so 50 years from now.
- Yes.
- 60, 70 years from now you're
gone, you've left this earth.
- 70 would be better go ahead.
- Yeah, 70, 115.
What's the contribution you have left.
- He gave way more than he took.
(upbeat music)